chicks where
My friends are in the official exam
Questions won't be written.
You will be shown on the screen a video showing someone
He talks and asks you the question.
So you should listen carefully.
and focus on understanding what is required of you
Answer the question correctly.
But I wrote you questions.
I will also write you the answers.
Until you get an idea and practice well on how to answer
In the Sabriken exam
The question means
What do you eat if your coworker has a baby?
And what do you say to her or him?
Dikh Nahar,
which is her,
they are his
Kalikha means a coworker.
Men and women alike are called no difference.
In that case you will answer
What is known in the Netherlands
In the Netherlands customs and traditions when a newborn is born
Parents provide guests with compliments
Any cake with colored granules
If the baby is male,
the grains are blue.
And if the newborn is a female,
the granules are pink
Design Oda Traditsi Nidalland
This is an old tradition in the Netherlands.
You should also memorize this information,
it will benefit you in an exam.
object or
So I can answer in that case.
Ak Ait
And tell her first
Blessed is the birth of your child hidden Lester
It means blessed or congratulations as we have it in the colloquial language
The brain of Porta Vanyo Baby,
with the birth of your child,
the brain of Porta birth